avec nous maintenant dominique lapointe
qui est économiste principal chez
valeurs mobilières banque laurentienne
bonsoir
l'a senti qu aujourd'hui que le
président de la réserve fédérale tentait
de se faire rassurant sur l'inflation
prudent même temps quelle est votre
perception
on n'a pas changé l'histoire ya de plus
en plus de pressions qui se font sentir
aux états unis posthume youkado sipo que
les banques centrales a juste sur
l'inflation l'histoire il le narratif
que nous aussi on on défend la banque
laurentienne c'est que l'inflation elie
à la hausse en raison de facteurs qui
sont généralement temporaire le est
mentionné en début d'émission autant
point de vue de l'offre et de la demande
les flashes ont continué à mon team mais
ces facteurs pourraient se rétablir
d'ici le début de l'an prochain
donc on ne crie à firmi cet enjeu lieu
cette histoire à la réserve fédérale ce
qui vient rassurer les marchés qu'on ne
va pas monter les taux d'intérêt de
manière préventive pour traîner
l'inflation et donc on va pas ralentir
l'économie au moment où il ya encore
beaucoup de chemin à faire surtout prévu
du marché de l'emploi mais il ya quand
même des signaux de réduction de
l'intervention de la réserve fédérale
dans les marchés financiers
effectivement le réseau fédéral à tout
le monde le mandat de l'inflation et on
vienne isère on pense que ça va se
rétablit autour de 2% entre h et donc ça
va bien
pour ce qui est du marché du travail en
corse mais enfin au point du par exemple
du chômage à long terme de chômage des
personnes au chômage des personnes
hispanique donc on s'attend encore à ce
que d'ici quelques mois on va voir
d'abord création d'emplois de création
d'emplois inclusive est large ce qui va
permettre selon jérôme baron et d'autres
membres du comité directeur des réseaux
fédérale de diminuer progressivement les
achats d'actifs dans l'économie ce qui
revient en quelque sorte à freiner
l'injection de liquidités qu'on fait
chaque mois il parle de sa monnaie
quelle importance vous percevez que la
fed donne l'effet négatif que pourrait
provoquer le variant delta
c'est très important selon nous si on
n'avait pas sûr que cette phase là
quatrième bague aux états unis en
fonction du variant delta probablement
qu'aujourd'hui dans le discours on
aurait annoncé un calendrier
pour disputer le ralentissement des
achats d'actifs et on ne réussit à un
rythme est-ce qu'on va diminuer de 10
milliards par maud avait mis à part
merci sarko aurait actionné marché tombe
pourquoi les taux d'intérêt baissent un
peu aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'on a pas
de calendrier l'on sent que membre
fédéral son équipier voici le
ralentissement économique en raison
supérieure dette au troisième trimestre
quatrième trimestre est ce que est ce
qu'il est clair pour vous donc que la
banque centrale sera très patiente et
sera même patient va attendre 2023 pour
amorcer sa hausse de taux c'est aussi ça
a été un des facteurs qui ont rassuré
les marchés financiers c'est qu'on a été
très clair à la fin du discours de
monsieur parole que même lorsqu on
aurait terminé le programme d'achat
d'actifs probablement au début de l'an
prochain d'après la moitié 2022 c'était
pas lié à des hausses de taux qui allait
survenir assez rapidement dans ce
qu'apple en 2014 quand on a terminé le
programme d'achat d'actifs ça a été
jusqu'en 2015 marco rossi tout pour la
première fois probablement ce genre de
scénario le convoi cette année pas de
hausse de taux avant 2023 dans le
processus de relance et de reprise
économique et des économistes qui
affirme que le passeport vaccinale
pourrait accélérer la reprise économique
ou ralentir la reprise pour les
provinces qui n'ont pas de passeport
vaccinale vous en pensez quoi vous
c'est pas nécessairement que ça va
accélérer la reprise d'entreprise qu'on
prévoit pour la deuxième moitié d'année
par exemple au québec elle est assez
forte avec une bonification d'entre eux
sait que ça va venir renforcer ce
scénario là dans la mesure où tout est
actif et intérieur où les gens se
rassemblent on va avant seulement des
jacks sont vaccinés on sait ça a été
très très bien démontré que les gens qui
sont pleinement vaccinés ont beaucoup
moins de chances d'attraper le virus ils
ont moins de symptômes ou si quand ils
ont le virus donc à ce moment là on va
éviter une quatrième bague
d'hospitalisation qui viendraient
entraîner d'une nouvelle fermeture dont
c'est vraiment point de vue de renforcer
les perspectives de passe par vaccinale
est positif pour l'équipe mais quand on
n'a pas de quand on met un passeport
vaccinale ont même plus de confiance
dans l'économie de la part des
consommateurs
ce qui n'est pas nécessairement le cas
si on n'a pas de passeport vaccinale qui
peut même entraîner une quatrième vague
encore plus forte a effectivement la
confiance les importantes par contre je
pense c'est important de russie ce qui
est important aussi c'est le taux de
vaccination dans la société il ya
plusieurs mesures qui peuvent être
utilisées pour faire en sorte que les
gens soient confiants de consommer et
des de sortir on voit beaucoup de
compagnies maintenant qu'ils vont exiger
la plaine vaccination au travail qui ont
mis des pénalités ces gens sont pas
vaccinés aux états unis on parle même de
peut-être réduire ou d'éliminer la
couverture d'assurance maladie si on
n'est pas vacciné on attrape le virus
donc ça va venir on espère augmenter
encore plus de niveaux de vaccination au
permettre à la confiance et la reprise
des plaines analyse très intéressante
dominique lapointe merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir merci pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit